we have a very very interesting story
involving a leaked audio tape there's
this really popular topic of
conversation now which is whether or not
collusion is a crime and this relates to
trump Russia in case you weren't aware
when we talk about is collusion a crime
it's not relating to I don't know it it
specifically is because of the Trump
Russia investigation that's going on
despite denying that collusion is a
crime Trump regularly calls for Hillary
Clinton to be investigated for colluding
with Russia
so it seems Trump on some level must
know that collusion can be criminal
yesterday we had a really great piece
from an LA Times article pointing out
that the Trump Russia meeting in and of
itself can be criminal Trump has claimed
that it's quote totally legal in a tweet
over the weekend but the meeting itself
also can be criminal but now we have
something pop potentially even more
interesting remember that guy Devin
Nunez he's the Republican member of the
House who for a while was running the
house investigation into Trump Russia
but then we found out he was secretly
going to the White House to tell Trump
exactly what it was that the
investigation was doing not something
that is morally acceptable ethically
acceptable and apparently that was what
pushed him over the edge and he was no
longer running that investigation yeah
and then he hinted that he was going to
recuse himself but continued running the
investigation it was all very weird and
lo and behold the House Intelligence
Committee didn't find any evidence of
Trump Russia collusion and shocking
shocking that they said case closed even
after talking to a missing key
interviews with witnesses but they said
we didn't find any wrongdoing so anyway
Devin Nunez there are secret recordings
which Rachel Maddow obtained where Devin
Nunez is explaining to donors at a
fundraiser about ten days ago that
actually yeah
collusion can be a criminal act this is
straight from the horse's mouth right
the guy who was there running the probe
in the house until he had to leave
because he was compromised saying
collusion can be criminal the leaked
audio came from the progressive group
fuse Washington who turned it over to
the Rachel Maddow Show take a listen to
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so let's explore what is Devon Nunez
sang here and what isn't Devon Nunez
saying Nunez is not saying what Trump
did is criminal okay that that's not
what Devon Nunez has caught on tape
saying here what Devon newness is saying
is the blanket statement that collusion
isn't illegal is flat-out wrong Trump
keeps repeating it Trump's attorney
repeats it other Republicans have been
repeating it collusion is not a crime
here is Devon Nunez behind closed doors
saying something completely
non-controversial for most of us but
it's not something you usually hear from
the right which is actually collusion
can be criminal now when confronted with
this audio of course they will say what
Nunez meant is if Trump had gotten the
dirt on Hillary and if that dirt on
Hillary had been illegally obtained and
if Trump released or used the dirt on
Hillary then and only then might it be
illegal but of course that's a
distraction because we already heard
yesterday from two legal experts in that
LA Times piece who explained the intent
to conspiracy to defraud the intent to
conspire to defraud I think better said
is a crime regardless of the outcome of
the attempt if you agree to meet with
Russia for the purposes of receiving
something in value of value dirt on
Hillary to help you win an election
you've received things of value from a
foreign country you have conspired with
them to defraud one of the fundamental
government agencies of the United States
the Federal Elections Committee which is
there to run fair elections free from
foreign influence even if you don't get
the dirt
even if you get the dirt but you don't
use the dirt the intent that you had
there already is the crime so it's not
hugely surprising that lots of talking
points around Trump Russia from the
Republicans are lies they seem to know
that they are publicly saying things
that aren't true and from this same
leaked tape by the way it's also
interesting that Nunez seems really
afraid of what happens to Republicans
and what happens to Trump if they lose
the house in November he seems genuinely
panicked and he should because he's part
of the problem that should be
investigated and if the Dems do take
over the House and Senate and then they
can start subpoenaing some of these
documents that Republicans haven't been
willing to turn turn over they can take
control of some of the committees that
should be doing some of these
investigations so a lot of what's going
on right now Nunez knows you need to
keep a Republican House and Senate to
protect yourself if they lose it a lot
of this stuff changes and that's why
people have to vote in November and you
may find this surprising but it looks
like Devin unas is pretty safe in his
district he has a Democratic challenger
at names Andrew Johns and apparently
back in June Nunez was eight points up
so who knows it is California it is like
the fresno area which is conservative it
could flip but as of now it looks like
noon this is pretty safe there yeah and
of course it's not a good about him
personally but it's about those 68
Republican held seats where the Democrat
currently is in better shape then what's
his name O'Connor was in Ohio's 12th
district special election earlier this
week so Nunez is panicked and
Republicans should be but only if we
actually go out and vote send me your
thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we
will take a quick break and be back
after this today's episode is made
possible in part by better help calm
slash Pakman I've spoken about the
unfair and unfortunate stigma that there
can be around therapy there shouldn't be
and better help makes things even easier
for you if you've been thinking about
getting involved and working with a
therapist you get access to fully
licensed experienced psychologists and
therapists through your phone or
computer all you have to do is go to
better help calm slash Pakman you fill
out a questionnaire they match you with
a counselor that'll work best
you you can ask if you want that your
therapist not be religious if that is
important to you and at any point if you
think your therapist is not a good fit
you can switch and work with somebody
else it's less expensive than seeing a
counselor in person but better help also
gives you unlimited access to your
counselor you can talk to them every day
if you want you will not get that with
an in-person therapist so go to better
help calm slash Pakman so easy to sign
up and get started we've put a link in
the video description if you're watching
on YouTube
check it out better help calm slash PA
que ma N